How is it that society has not learned
from history about the dangers of
socialism,
Marxism,
ideology,
et Cetera,
after years,
how to Marxists get away with it?
Well,
let's,
let's not go with the dangers of etiology.
Let's go with the dangers of like
call it radical left wing ideology.
Well,
I think the reason for this,
and this also might buy the reason,
be the reason that there's a strange
thing that the iconography of,
of social communism is
still acceptable socially,
whereas the iconography of Nazi-ism isn't.
Now,
I'm not saying that we should make the
icons of Nazi as socially acceptable
either.
I think that the communist icon
shouldn't be socially acceptable,
but they are.
And there's probably a reason for that.
You know,
now,
part of it is that the
left has never taken on.
The radical left has ne never
taken responsibility for
being on the same side as
the Stalinists and the Maoists and the
Cambodian murderers and all of that.
So that's part of it.
But then the next part is I
think there's something deeper.
I think that,
you know,
inequality is a reality and it's a
reality that cannot be put at the feet of
capitalism or at the feet of
human political structure.
There's a good book you guys might want
to read this called the great leveler by
Walter Shy Dale and it's a new book
and it's the study of inequality.
And one of the things he does is do an
empirical analysis of the relationship
between inequality,
the Gini Coefficient,
which is a measure of inequality and
the ideological position of governments.
So here's the theory.
The hypothesis would be,
well,
because the left wingers are
concerned with inequality,
if you measured inequality in left wing
under left wing governments and you
measured inequality under
right wing governments,
you'd expect a reduction in inequality
under left wing governments.
And the results are
okay,
no difference.
And so what does that mean?
It doesn't mean that left
wings are hypocrites,
although it might mean that
because people can be hypocrites.
But what it means is the problem of
inequality is so intractable that we don't
know of any appropriate
political sociological or economic
solutions that actually work.
It's a real catastrophe.
Now,
inequality in itself might not be a
bad thing unless it's too extreme.
It's extreme.
When people say start to starve
and then clearly somethings,
you know it's,
it's very difficult to,
I think everyone would agree
that that's a suboptimal outcome.
You know,
we don't need to get all
ideological about that,
but some degree of
inequality is useful because,
well,
it gives people something to strive for.
It gives them an op,
right?
It means,
I was thinking about this,
sometimes you actually want people to
be rich because if a new product is
introduced into the market,
the people there have to be people around
who have substantial pools of capital
to be able to afford it
when it's still novel.
And then that market brings the
price down for everyone else.
And so if everyone had
exactly the same income,
it would be very difficult to introduce
expensive products into the market with
the hope that their price would plummet.
Not actually is a big deal.
You want large pools of
capital sitting around too,
so that people can invest in very,
very complex things.
And you also want large pools of capital
to be the hands have to be in the hands
of private individuals so
that there's competitive,
there's forces that are powerful,
that are competitive with the government
and with other large organizations.
So anyways though,
back to the Marxists,
despite the fact that there are reasons
for inequality and despite the fact that
you can't lay the fact of inequality at
the feet of capitalism and despite the
fact that capitalism also appears to be
making every one not absolutely poor at
the same time as it makes
some people very rich,
there's still inequality is still painful
reality and no one really likes it.
You know?
I mean you can lord it over someone,
I suppose,
and,
and extract out some sense of your
moral superiority because you happen to
occupy a hierarchical
position that's higher.
And sometimes there's
some validity in that,
especially if you've earned it.
Although I would say like glorying in
it is probably a suboptimal outcome.
It's still the case that that inequality
violates a moral intuition that
everyone has.
I think,
and that's probably the moral intuitions
that lie along the agreeable access.
It's like,
well,
wouldn't it be better
if everyone had enough?
It's like,
well,
who argues with that?
You know,
I mean,
everyone feels that way.
And so I think,
um,
a thoughtless,
a thoughtless compassion makes Marxism,
okay.
Naively attractive.
And I'm not being cynical about that
because there is some utility in naive
agreeableness,
but unfortunately the world
is a very complicated place.
And merely wanting to be nice about things
and wishing that everything was fair
doesn't justify imposing an
equity outcome and Gerrymandering,
complex economic systems that will bite
you if you mess with them because you're
ideologically possessed.
I am 46,
retired executive,
wealthy,
competent and full of Jews.
Who could I talk to if I want to invest
time slash money slash energy in your
university
people,
lots of people are,
are asking me such things and
it's very much appreciated.
It's a weird,
you know,
because you'd think that if people are
offering you time and money that it would
be a straight forward thing to say,
yes,
please climb aboard and help.
But it's not that simple
because first of all,
I don't want to involve people in
something that I can't be sufficiently
committed to.
It's not fair to them.
Um,
and it isn't obvious to me how I can be
committed to this yet fully committed to
it.
And so I'm sort of playing with
it at the level that I can manage.
It's not like it's a game.
We have a good product in
involved or a good product in,
in motion at the moment,
but I'm not,
I don't have the wherewithal
to scale at the moment.
And you know,
you can say,
and people who are developing
new businesses like to do this,
like let's say I could come up with
a draft business plan for an online
university and then I could
contact people like you,
Paul and say,
look,
I'm ready to gather investments in,
let's say I could raise $20 million or
let's say I could raise $200 million.
Then I have a new problem.
The problem is,
well,
Oh my God,
I've got all this money now I have to
figure out something to do with it.
And that's actually a
really big responsibility.
Not,
it's not like,
you know,
it's a success catastrophe,
let's say it's a first world problem.
I get all that,
but that doesn't mean that it isn't real.
So I have to do a lot
more thinking and planning
and figure out how to disperse my time
most effectively before I dare to take on
any additional people
who would like to help.
Now,
once my organization as it is in a
place where that sort of help would be
useful,
then I'll make a public announcement and
I would be more than happy for people
to jump on board.
Let's say climb on board,
start pushing,
devote resources,
all of those things.
I'd be happy for that to happen that,
but I don't want to do it prematurely
because I don't want people to,
to risk their valuable resources in
an endeavor that isn't yet solid.
So,
all right,
so I'm only going to do,
I think one more question.
Um,
I am a sober alcoholic slash drug addict.
How can I find my way back to belief
in a higher power after 10 years in the
empty void of atheism,
I'm falling apart.
Well,
I would say your best bet is to
actually start devoting some time to it.
You know,
for me,
I became convinced of the
validity of a religious viewpoint.
I think as a consequence of study
read,
Joseph Campbell read
Carl Young Young's hard.
Campbell's a good introduction though.
Richa Ellie out as well.
I don't know if you can find
your way back to belief,
but you might be able to find your way
back to meaningful engagement and that
might,
that's a better way of thinking about it.
You know,
the belief thing is a really tricky one.
People ask me,
do you believe in God?
And I think,
I really think,
how dare you ask that question.
I think that's really what I think.
Yeah.
But on a more prosaic level,
I usually think,
well,
I don't know what you mean by belief.
I don't know what you mean by belief
and I don't know what you mean by God.
These are very,
these,
these are very difficult questions
and none of that self evident.
Now I would say,
do I believe in the crucifixion?
Well,
certainly,
I mean people,
the crucifixion,
how can you not believe in it if,
if you think symbolically,
it's like human beings are,
we're eternally crucified,
right?
Our lives are tragic and
they end in death and were,
we're all betrayed.
We're all betrayed.
We all experienced betrayal.
So how could you,
you can't not believe in the crucifixion.
Do you believe in the resurrection?
Well,
people die and are reborn all the time.
You know,
they go through,
this is what you're after here.
I'm a sober drug and
alcohol and drug addict.
Well,
you know,
you,
you had to let a lot of you die when you
stop being an addict and something new
be reborn.
It's like what's the ultimate significance
of that and how is it tied to the
notion of bodily resurrection?
Well,
I don't know what the
ultimate significance is,
but it does seem to be
the pathway through life
to believe.
I would say you start
believing not by attempting to
convince yourself that the
statement there is a god is true,
like a fact is true,
but to act out the proposition that you
should shoulder your cross and stumble
uphill towards the city of God.
That's belief,
man,
and you can do that
right away.
Now you might ask,
well,
do I have any guarantee that that has
transcendent and universal significance?
It's like,
well,
it's not a bad model for emulation.
It has universal
significance in that regard.
We each have to shoulder the tragedy
of our existence and stumble upwards.
Despite that it has
universal significance.
Does it have significance outside of
life and like get the internal eternal
realm?
Okay.
I wouldn't surprise me if it did.
I suppose it depends on what
you mean by the eternal realm.
The
seems to have significance in the
eternal realm of consciousness.
It seems to have significance in the
eternal realm of unconscious fantasy,
implicit fantasy and mythology.
How is it connected
with the factual world?
Okay.
That's a hard question because the factual
world in some sense divorced itself
from that transcendental world during
the development of the scientific
methodology.
So never the Twain shall meet.
It's a methodological issue.
In part,
I think you probably have to draw on the
same forces that enabled you to sober
up and abandoned your drug addiction.
No,
something was guiding you forward.
Go forward again,
go forward again,
as if there is a higher power.
That's your manifestation of faith.
Go forward again,
as if being is benevolent and God is good.
That's the hallmark of courage
and that's a good place to stop.
Thank you all for showing up today and uh,
and for all the support and,
and that's enough for March,
March 4th,
2018 bye bye.